we've got 4 x squared y minus 3xy plus
25 minus the entire expression 9y
squared x plus 7xy
minus 20. so when we're subtracting this
entire expression that's equivalent to
subtracting each of these terms
individually if we didn't have the
parentheses or another way of thinking
about it we could distribute this
negative sign or you could view this as
a negative one
times this entire expression and we can
distribute it so let's do that so let me
write this first expression here i'm
going to write it unchanged so it is 4 x
squared y
minus 3 x y
plus 25 and now let me distribute the
negative 1 or the negative sign times
all of this stuff so negative 1 times 9y
squared x is
negative 9 y squared x negative 1 times
7 x y is negative
7 x y and then negative 1 times 20 is
positive 20.
and now we just have to add these terms
and we just want to group like terms so
let's see is there another x squared y
term anywhere i don't see one so i'll
just write i'll just rewrite this
so we have 4 x squared y
now is there another x y term yeah there
is so we can group negative 3xy and
negative 7
xy negative 3 of something minus another
7 of that something is going to be
negative 10 of that something so it's
negative 10
x y
and then we have see we have a 25 which
is just a constant term or an x to the
zero term is 25x to zero you could view
it that way there's another constant
term right over here we can always add
25 to 20 that gives us 45
and then we have this term right over
here which clearly can't be merged with
anything else so minus nine
y squared let me do that in that
original color
minus
nine
no i'm having trouble shifting colors
minus nine y is squared x and we are
done